good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you're joining us
from welcome to simply learn we are
honored to have us join today for ypmp
with your host bruce fiegen
my name is richard and after this intro
i'll be mostly in the background helping
bruce so that everything goes smoothly
ypmp
project management professional pmp is a
standard in today's project management
professional world and being trained and
certified and is different aspects would
help anyone's career and is a must for
managing a companies or businesses
project needs
if you are not familiar with birds bruce
is a project management guru taking
people's complex ideas
and resolve them into accomplishable
tasks
he loves to share his knowledge and help
others succeed president of roundtable
project management project manager
trainer and consultant at cadence
management corporation trainer uh he's
gone to
boston university or trainer boston
university corporate education center
vice president the list is just really
long in his history and his experience
he has numerous publications out how to
plan a project assumptions improve
project and product quality
a practical method to track percentage
complete using earned value analysis
went to the universe
to introduce you to your dashboard or
control board
if everyone could locate your dashboard
or control board and then locate the
question module
go ahead and message hello in the
question module just say hi to bruce and
let him know you're excited to be here
this also lets me know you're hearing us
uh go ahead and do that now
let me get on
let's see is there be in there yeah if
you go and i see someone over there we
go paddy hi bruce great to have you
patty
uh cash app i hope i said your name
right great to have you
left excellent great to have everybody
on board
nice
all right this question module is your
best friend as bruce feegan is going
through his presentation type in a
question and we can address it
um at the end for clarification we have
like a 15-minute q a
we'll get to as many questions as we can
also if there's something in there like
you need us to slow down or something's
breaking up just give us a quick note in
there
if you hear something awesome brilliant
interesting and you want to share in
your social channels whatever your
social channels are facebook linkedin
tweet you can use the hashtag sl
webinars that way people can find it and
you will make them jealous and wish they
were here with us
you didn't come here to listen to me i
am proud to introduce bruce
who will be your host for ypmp go ahead
and sit back relax have a cup of coffee
tea or if it's evening where you're at
maybe a glass of wine and enjoy it's an
honor for me to hand this over to bruce
feegan thank you and happy learning
bruce
well hello everybody glad you could join
us we have quite a big crowd here so it
should be interesting we'll leave quite
a bit of time to answer all the
questions you come up with
so the pmp i received my pmp back in
1999 and so i can
say i got in the last millennium
and
at that time nobody knew what it was i
had to
explain to people that pmp wasn't my
night job it actually met a
certification but now that's changed i
think i was pnp number 14 000 i think
now there's there's close to a million
pmps out there
and you maybe you're considering it
yourself which is why you're attending
this this seminar
and
it's really become a very valuable
asset uh there's been some studies done
showing that it adds ten thousand
dollars a year to your salary
there's uh there's a lot of jobs you
just can't get unless you have a pmp and
it
it gives you instant credibility when
you say hey i'm a project manager a lot
of people are going to ask you do you
have your pmp or are you going for your
pnp and if you don't
um you don't have that credibility
so it's it's a great
it's a great
certification to have it's worldwide
but it costs some money right it costs
some money to sit for the test the last
thing you want to do is pay that money
sit for the test do all the all the um
preparation to
show that you are prepared for it and
then fail the test have to repay do it
again so what a lot of people are doing
are attending boot camps like what
simply learn has out there
that gives you all the knowledge for how
to pass the test
now the clear the thing you need to
understand is that
passing your pmp and learning how to be
a project manager are two
distinctly different
skill sets two different classes you can
take
i do teach both and and i found that
they're quite different
you learned a lot in a pnp class
about how to do things in a way that i
would consider wrong
you would never want to actually do in
real life
such as don't tell your boss when things
are going wrong
if you want to have a successful career
you want to make sure that you are doing
you're keeping your boss well informed
but as far as far as pmi is concerned
the pmp test is concerned you are this
god-like project manager who can do
anything
and um
everything is within your powers and
your boss didn't know anything your job
is to just solve everything by yourself
so um
you know with that in mind understand
when you take the pnp test you need to
learn the way
pmi thinks about projects
and that's why this class is very
important because it teaches you not
just how to break down this project
management body of knowledge into all
different process groups and knowledge
areas but also how to think like a pmi
member
we have a lot of hints in this class a
lot of
a lot of philosophy in there about
the way pmi thinks about these different
things
so i i want to show some some of the
more interesting parts of this um
there's some interesting things here in
project human resource management that
thank god actually coincides with what
good project managers learn as well so
i'm going to show you a particular slide
here
that is useful and i don't know why my
thing is beeping let me try that there
we go
all right so
one of the most
complex
parts of a project actually the most
complex part of a project are the people
dealing with people
makes your life a lot more difficult
it's really easy to to plan a project
and execute a project if it's just you
and you uh
you don't have to interact with other
people but the fact is you you will have
to deal with other people and so dealing
with other people
there's three different areas in which
you need to be concerned the first one
is is sociology how do you deal with a
group of people that's what this slide
is all about
um after i go through this slide i'll
give you a brief slide on uh individual
dealing with individual which of course
is the field of psychology
and
then there's dealing with different
cultures nowadays it seems like every
project is multicultural and so there's
a whole
group of
a whole study called anthropology and
there's a lot of good books written
about that
um but let's start with the sociological
part forming storming normally
performing a journey you may have heard
of this before it's it's known as the
tuckman model and it was uh it's
actually based on the charier
model back in the 50s but
this one has nice rhyming words so it's
easy to understand and the theory behind
this is pretty straightforward you get
any group of people together to start
something
they they start out forming where the
team comes together morale is nice and
high because we're all doing something
new
uh but productivity is low
you know you're you're in there you're
sitting in the room you're you're
drinking your tea and thinking well what
are we here for i don't know uh
something about this new project do you
wonder what it's all about oh it's about
this really
ah that's that's a great project i've
always wanted this project to come along
so that we can sell this to our
customers and then somebody says no no
no we're not we're not about
satisfying our customers we're reducing
the uh scrap problems we have in this
the current product and somebody said no
no no it's not nothing to do with that
it's it's about
reducing complaints and somebody else
thinks it's about making more sales and
what are we doing we're in this storming
phase where people are arguing about
what this project is really all about
so at this point the project manager
whoever is leading that group needs to
play a very active role they need to be
involved and making sure people don't
come to fisticuffs and and
sever some relationships because these
people need to be working together in
the long run
so
we need to have a very high active role
here to
to keep things moving
because what we need to do is move from
the storming phase of the norming phase
the norming phase being
how do how what can we all agree upon
this project is all about
the way i do this on every one of my
projects is i i have what's called an
objective statement uh this was a this
was something invented by the by nasa
back in the 50s
where every project has a sentence
25 words or less that encompasses four
of the main constraints of any project
the cost of the project
the schedule of the project and what
nasa called performance it's a
combination of of
scope and quality those two are combined
in there
and so for every
every project they had one of these
objectives and
the forging of one of these objectives
is a really great way of getting through
this storming into the norman phase
because
what we do is we come to agreement on
what this project is the scope is all
about we are doing this we're not doing
that i'm going to make this compromise
you're going to make that compromise and
eventually we come to agreement with uh
with what we're going to do once the
group then is normed then they can move
into the performing phase
let's go back to look at what was
happening throughout this process in
terms of morale and in terms of
productivity
so morale was high remember when we were
in the forming phase everyone's all
happy and something new
when they start arguing nobody likes
that and morale plummets people are
feeling really bad productivity has
actually dropped significantly as well
because
not only are we not accomplishing
anything we're actually
um
arguing with each other which which
tends to make productivity even lower
but when we get into the forming into
the norming phase
we start
coming to agreements on what we're what
we're going to move together towards
then morale starts coming back up people
are
being friendly again
and productivity is starting to go up
and then we can move up into this
performing phase where
we've got high productivity and high
morale at that point the
project manager the leader of this group
can back off the the amount of
management they have to do they could be
less directive and more participative
and and eventually when the the teams
are reaching this high performing stage
the project manager is almost invisible
they're just gathering the results of
what the team is creating and um
everything's moving smoothly
now
the theory here and i've seen it in
practice is that you cannot skip a step
you can't just go from forming straight
to performing without going through the
storming and norming phase
and when you are in the performing phase
it doesn't mean that you're stuck there
for good
um arguments will come up things will
change on a project which forces you
back into the
back into the storming phase and you've
got to come back as a project manager
and start facilitating those
people moving back towards the norming
phase
and then eventually uh getting back into
the performing phase
but let's go back to nasa for a minute
um
i'm assuming we have a fairly young
audience in here
but uh there's people who us watch the
history channel and people who read
history
so let me give you a couple of examples
of some of the more famous objective
statements that nasa put put out there
so for instance there was the viking
project
the viking objective and remember the
the pattern here was a sentence 25 words
or less that encompasses the cost
schedule and the performance which is
scope and quality so here's the viking
objective fly to mars and take pictures
in six years for six billion dollars
right very succinct statement very
memorable fly to mars take pictures at
six years for six billion dollars it
encompasses the the cost right six
billion dollars the schedule six years
and the performance which in this case
is fly to mars and take pictures
uh get ready to put a comment in here
because i'm going to
test your knowledge here in a moment
all right so
let's think now about the apollo program
the apollo program was all about um
going to the moon
so
back in 1960 one john f kennedy gives a
speech to the nation where he presents
two-thirds of the official apollo
objective he didn't present the the cost
portion because he didn't want to give
people heart attacks
when they found out the thing was going
to cost 40 billion dollars
so
what i'd like you to do is see if
anybody can recreate the objective of
the apollo program so
type in the
chat area what you think the apollo
objective is all about i'll give you a
couple of minutes to do that
see what you guys come up with i'll read
them out as i see them
i can put the i can sing the jeopardy
tune if you'd like if that makes it any
easier
no takers nobody wants to uh
here we go get to the moon in return oh
pati angelos
not only
hit the main objective which was uh to
accomplish a man do the landing but she
oh a few of the other people got them
too all right who's googling this i just
have to ask all right but that's that's
very important part the official
objective was to achieve a man luna
landing and safe return of the astronaut
because
that made that project a little more
complicated than just sending a man to
the moon was the safe return of the
astronaut required a re-entry vehicle
required a lunar module all these other
different parts so
um
so that's a uh
that was the official objective to fly
the moon
to accomplish a manned lunar landing and
safe return the astronaut by the end of
the decade which in that case was uh
september 30th 1970 because we operated
on the government fiscal year
at a cost not to exceed 40 billion
so good glad to see that
um we had a funny coming today i think
provide the states with the strategic
head over rival states yeah there was uh
that was a
we definitely were fighting against the
russians at that point we didn't want
them to get too far ahead okay but very
good every project
i like to put them through this because
it forces the people to go from forming
where they're all polite and everything
the
to through the storming where we're
fighting about what the objective of
this project is all about
and then coming to agreement
on what the project really is about
based on the fact that we do not have
infinite time we don't have infinite
money
and
we
we have to limit the scope in order to
come to an agreement
so once you put them through there it's
usually a high point in in the project
planning session we start out with a
with a background we go through the
objective statement and that's usually
about time for the for the early morning
break
and people are feeling pretty good and
shaking hands all around
and ready to plan the rest of the
project
so we've got trust developed within the
team and then
given that people can start moving
forward
so that's a uh
that's the one lesson i'd like people to
learn about um
about sociology is this whole forming
storming norming performing part
adjourning is is a uh is a different
thing
i think they mostly put it on here as a
as a nice way to have another word that
rhymes with performing
but
the sharier society had a little better
thing called the esprit de corps the
esprit de corps was when you have a team
that's worked together for quite a while
they've been in the performing phase
everybody trusts each other they like
each other they felt like they've
accomplished all these wonderful things
and now they want to
they want to
move on to the next project they don't
want the project to end they want to go
to phase two they want to
um take another project that's similar
and all work together because we trust
each other we don't want to we don't
want to part or hey let's all
quit this lousy place and start our own
company and and work together for the
rest of our lives is
some teams reach this great
state of esprit de corps
and uh i've seen it a couple of times
but most teams
they're kind of happy to let go and
start a new project again
anybody had similar experiences
all right so that's what i want to show
you on
on
sociology the next one is psychology
now psychology there's all kinds of
different ways of looking at different
people
um
you might have heard of myers-briggs or
the disc system or any other
of these uh
ideas where they take people and they
break them up into
the different different personality
types
but really the father of all this was
actually the father of medicine
3000 years ago hippocrates
put out his four personality styles and
his theory was that the different
personality styles were caused by
different
over amounts of certain body fluids like
someone has too much blood or too much
yellow bile or too much phlegm or too
much black bile
quite an interesting theory and and uh
what i'm going to do is show you the
four basic personality styles based on
the two by two matrix
if you see on the top left
on the
y axis we have introverted versus
extrovert there are people and you
you've you know this that there are
people who are more extroverted than
others are people who would like to
speak in public versus people who prefer
not to speak in public
and then on the x-axis we see are
people who are more people oriented they
like dealing with people and there are
people who are more task oriented they
prefer dealing with tasks
so we can plot hippocrates for
four styles on this on this graph
he also had it split up as people who
are air people who are fire water and
earth
so
the important thing to note about these
different personality styles is that we
all have them
we all have our own personality style we
all fit somewhere on this on this matrix
um and our personality style probably
annoys somebody else unless we're right
in the middle there somewhere we annoy
other people
and there are times
in the project lifetime that you need to
you need to influence somebody to to
work on behalf of your project either
you're hiring a team member or you're
trying to get a team member to do some
work or you're trying to get someone to
senior staff to
to break down some obstacle or you're
trying to make the customer buy your
product whatever there's times when we
need to influence people
to
make our project run smoothly
and when we're trying to influence
somebody we don't want to come in with
an opposite personality acting extremely
opposite from from their personality
because it's just not going to work
so what i want to do is give you a very
exaggerated version of these different
styles
so
if i'm not sure if you can see my mouse
but if
when i first talk about the extrovert
i'm going to talk about the top left
corner of this box about the really
extreme extroverts i'm going to talk
about the bosses i'm going to talk about
the top right and the
amiables on the bottom left and the
analyticals i'm going to be talking
about the bottom right
we'll have a bit of fun with this we'll
i'll be doing some exaggerations but
you'll get my point so let's start with
the extroverts so the extrovert is
somebody who is is wild and exuberant
and waves their hands around in the air
and wears
very colorful clothing and drives a
drives a very obnoxious
very uh colorful car we'll say
when they come into a room of people
they look around the room and they're oh
this is fantastic i'm gonna go
over here and talk to this person for a
while and after i've talked to alvin for
a little while um in the middle of a
conversation i'm going to turn around
and i'm going to look at the distance
and i'm going to see webster over there
i'm going to just walk away from alvin
and go talk to webster because that's
interesting to me i'm always uh
attracted by bright colors and and new
things and uh meanwhile alvin's going
what why did he just walk away did i say
something rude but meanwhile i've
already left webster and i've gone take
a look at juan and chatted with him and
for me a great party is a party when
i've met everyone and everyone has had a
taste of bruce and how wonderful i am
and and
you know i just think i'm like the gift
to the world as an extrovert everybody
should get a get a taste of me and
so how do you uh
how do you deal with these people uh if
you are an extroverted person
one of the things you want to do if
you're extremely extroverted is you want
to
smooth off some of these rough edges
so understand that that is an annoying
activity you are
by by starting a conversation with
somebody and then looking over their
shoulder and then just leaving them
going to talk to somebody else that is
considered very rude to somebody who's
on the opposite side of the equation
anybody who's
amiable or analytical go why did he just
do that
another thing extroverts do they have
they have positives in that they love to
start new things it's always exciting to
to tell them about something new they
they want to start it up immediately and
get deeply involved in it but when it
starts getting boring they're like all
right i'm done and they're out of there
and they leave things
hanging
right so
is it good to have one extra vote on
your team
probably because these people are
energetic and exciting and and they
they love to start new things but you
can't
trust them to actually finish that stuff
so you don't want a full team made up of
extroverts
now let's look over here
um at the
at the people who have oh by the way how
do you get how did um
hippocrates say you cure this well you
just drain some of their blood
you uh do one of those bloodletting
procedures and you'd be surprised at how
much extrovert calms down when you have
uh
you have taken a lot of their blood out
it's just kind of like after you've done
a blood donation you don't feel that
energetic anymore so maybe hippocrates
was onto something right
all right let's look now at the at the
yellow bile people they have too much
fire
they're the boss
okay so
the boss
this is a person who's very task
oriented he doesn't care about people at
all once again i'm showing the people
right up here at the very top right
so
the boss he he looks
you can recognize him by the way you
walk into his office his desk is
completely clear there's not a scrap
paper on there if you hand him anything
to deal do with he'll grab it he'll make
a decision right away hand it right back
to you good clean desk again i'm excited
you look behind him he's got the wall of
fame there's all the patents and
certificates and
and his degrees and everything are all
framed nicely and all perfectly aligned
on the wall behind him
wears very uh conservative clothes
suit the tie
when he comes into our party he doesn't
care about people he looks around and
goes all right where's that person i
need to have make a decision there he is
all right it's it's karen all right
karen come over here
remember
this meeting we're having tomorrow i
want to make sure you're ready for this
that the other uh these are the points
you need to get across and the decision
is x y z good all right you're done now
i'm done with you
who else can i look at let's look at uh
shiny shiny uh all right here you are
hey i've got a piece of paper in my
backpack but i need you to sign this
don't even look at it just sign it
that's all good all right taking that
away
and uh i'm done with it running this
party i've got a bit of better things to
do and they're out there
great at getting things done
really bad at dealing with people
so
would you like to have one of them on
your project probably it's good to have
somebody who can get those decisions
made and not worry about how everybody's
feelings
but
you wouldn't want an entire team made up
of
of the bosses
so um
how do you smooth off your rough edges
understand that people
especially on this left side of this
equation people are
they care that other people care about
themselves they want you to ask them
about how their family how was it
weekend
you know you don't have to go straight
to the point get to know people they'll
work for you better if they
if they feel like you actually care
about them not just the work that
they're doing
so that's how you want to smooth off
those rough edges
all right let's go down here oh how do
you get rid of them the the yellow bile
they can throw up right they've got too
much yellow bile um give them a medic
make this
kneel over a toilet for a while and
you'd be surprised how much these people
calm down so yeah
i'm kind of liking what uh
what hippocrates had to come up with 3
000 years ago
all right next group the amiable people
these are very people oriented but very
introverted people they tend to be uh
very muted if the
women they tend to wear muted makeup
pastel colors
um they're not going to make any kind of
a scene when they come to a part they
kind of settle in they look around like
oh my god do i know anybody in this room
oh good there's somebody i know
uh randy i'm gonna sneak over to randy
and i'm gonna sit and chat with him
and my entire goal this evening is to
just have a really good long
conversation with randy so that i can
come home and tell my wife that i just i
felt like i made this great connection
with randy that was just a successful
party with me we just connected on a
real basic
way we
both have kids around the same age
and we talked about the schooling
how do you recognize these people
elsewhere if you look at their office
um a lot of pictures of the family
around
um they're very family-oriented oriented
people
how do you solve their problem well the
barcode says they've got too much phlegm
you got to give them a neti pot and
flush out their their sinuses and be
surprised how they wake up
now what's the good part and the bad
part about the the
amiable people are really good at making
connections keeping people happy they
get very nervous when uh they see people
not getting along so they're a really
good bridge to go across these people
and
make sure everyone's everyone's being
happy
um but they're not good at is
finishing anything they're they're big
procrastinators they
similar to the extroverts and that they
they don't get things done but while the
extrovert will say i don't i didn't do
it because i'm bored
the
phlegmatic people will say well you know
yeah i'll get to it tomorrow i'll get to
tomorrow and and they just tend to
procrastinate so watch out for that
so how do these people annoy you well
can you imagine this amible
talking to the boss
all right the amiable comes into the
boss's office the bus is sitting there
behind his desk ready to make decisions
and the angel walks and goes hi how's it
going how was your weekend
harry kid how's your dog how's your
second cousin and the
boss is just sitting there drumming his
fingers and saying we've got to get to
that point get to the point what do you
want
so um you've got to understand as an
amiable you annoy people by doing that
so you've got to think about who you're
dealing with and say um boss here's what
i need uh can you just sign this
document for me all right opposite of
when the the boss person comes into the
animal office you don't want to come
charging in they say sign this for me
right now
if you want to influence these people
you need to
sit down have a conversation talk about
the weather talk about family as much as
possible but
make sure you make a connection with
this person before you ask them to do
something all right next one the black
bile people these these have too much
black bile
um
these are task oriented introvert people
the analytical uh we'll call them the
nerd um the people who extroverts will
call them the nerds by the way the nerds
will call these people flanks the
extroverts
everyone's got a bad name as well as a
good name the boss is called the jerk
the aimable is called the wimp
and the analytical is called the nerd
so
these people um
are all about numbers that's that's what
they care about they they want to look
look around and try to put numbers on
everything they don't want to they don't
care about people
um
and they're not going to be out there
they're the kinds of work in the party
going oh my god there's all these people
here
uh let's see is there anybody here who
likes star wars that i can talk to ah
bobby let's go talk to bobby for a
little while so they'll have quiet
conversations with bobby but the
conversations are all about numbers and
and uh connections and things like that
it's not it's not um they don't really
care about people
so
how do they annoy people well they annoy
people by not
talking about people at all but they
they only seem to care about numbers and
figures and excel spreadsheets how do
you recognize them by the way their
office will
have excel spreadsheets on display or
access databases or all kinds of
statistical analyses that that's
the kind of thing that turns them on you
won't see family pictures in these
in these black bile people
so how do you
how do you attract them
i have to talk to them about numbers
figure out what it is that you want to
influence and convert it into something
that that has numbers on it and
tell them about that
all right so
how do they annoy people how do we
smooth off their rough edges if you are
one of these
extreme black bile people
other than hibachi's idea which is to uh
to
give you a uh
what do you call an enema
which will kind of wake anybody up um
what you need to do is is um
start thinking about other people think
about what what people might want to
hear not just numbers
and um
you know put yourself in the position of
what an extrovert might want to hear you
know don't don't go straight into the
numbers start talking about some other
things beat your way around the bush
what are they good at they're really
good at finishing the jobs that the
others don't finish you know the the
extrovert and the amiable will start
stuff and just let it go
anybody says yeah i'm finishing
finishing it but never does
the analytical just loves putting all
the things back into places and getting
it getting it organized
so would you want one of these people on
your team yeah it's great to have
somebody who can finish the work the
other start
you wouldn't want a full team made up of
these people
so
the key things here are
very few people are really on the
extremes you know very few people are on
the far corners of here people tend to
be
somewhere in the middle my personality
if you want to know is more extroverted
when i'm at work i'm probably a little
off to the d in in blood but when i'm
home i tend to be more of the um i'm
probably around where the
yellow is in yellow bile
still very extroverted but but more task
oriented when i get home kind of
interesting
um but
most people when you plot yourself on
this matrix where the people are first
task oriented extroverted versus
introverted you tend to be more in the
middle
what you won't see are people you will
see people who are you know mixed across
like
yellow and red or or yellow and black or
black and blue or
red and blue you almost never see people
who are mixed
in the opposites like you'll never see a
black and
a red person or a yellow and blue person
unless
and that's very interesting i was
teaching this class once and
we were
we gave we gave little surveys where
people fill it out answer a bunch of
questions to kind of figure out where
you are and we had surveys given out to
other people to um
to figure out what other people thought
of you to get a pretty balanced
perspective of what your personality
style is
and there was one person who was indeed
both yellow and blue
and i was just in the process of saying
the only time you see this is if there
if it's some kind of a
defense mechanism where you really are
this type but maybe your parents beat
that out of you and force you to become
this type so that's where you have that
mix or there's a mental illness and he
said oh yeah well actually i have
bipolar disease and that's why i like
that it's like oh okay
a little too much information for a
company meeting but really prove my
point
so
what's what's the key thing here as a
none of this
stuff
will be on the
pmp test the hot cold wet dry etc
however
the myers-briggs will appear you kind of
need to know
you need to know about personality
styles in order to
to pass one or two questions on the pmp
test but this whole
thing that i just gave you very valuable
for actually being a project manager you
will need to
deal with different people you'll need
to deal with different people
when they're having bad days and so
recognizing that
you may not have the exact same
personality as the other people you're
trying to influence on your team is
important
so you need to
think about how i'm going to influence
that person based on what their
personality is
you need to recognize another person's
personality
so let's go over that again quickly
extroverted people they're pretty easy
to see they're out there they're they're
throwing their arms around they're
wearing wild colors that drive a
loud automobile
the
bosses the yellow bile people they're
they're
very
conservatively dressed their office has
nothing that may have a wall of fame
behind them they have nothing on their
desk
the amiable people have kind of a messy
office but there's pictures of uh
of their family around and the
analytical people will have some kind of
number spreadsheets
star wars figurines things like that in
there in their office so recognize the
person that you're trying to influence
while you can't change your personality
your personality is pretty much there
from birth i know
i had two i had twins and
their personality was set from birth and
they're now 16 years old and they still
have the same personality as they had
it's quite different they're both raised
the same way but they they just have
different personalities so you can't
change your personality and act a little
bit differently
when you need to influence people so you
may be planning on having a 10-minute
conversation with somebody of an
opposite personality style
think about how your personality
annoys other people smooth out those
rough edges and try to mirror their type
of personality during the time that
you're speaking with them when you're
done you can go back to your normal
person normal personality
this takes some practice so there's
nothing wrong with
getting some practice in just saying hey
you know what uh
i'm going to
have lunch with this uh boss type person
i'm going to act like him for lunch even
though i don't need anything from him
i'm just going to act like him just to
get to practicing and being that type of
personality and do that with the
different people so that when time comes
for you to
to
try to influence them you already have
that muscle in the memory memory in the
muscle of uh how to do that to people
all right um
i've
done i've said what i wanted to say now
i'm going to start going through some of
these questions here
and see
see what
how i can answer them
so reggie's had i am from i.t so for me
scrum certification feels more feasible
but want to know how different pmp from
scrum master certification is
yeah see i'm the opposite um i haven't
got a scrum certification though i have
seen it from the outside
but i understand that it is actually
quite different um
the pmp certification it's
there's
certain requirements you have to have 4
500 hours of
project management experience you have
to have 40 hours of actual
training and then you really need to sit
through some kind of a
of a boot camp in order to ensure
yourself being able to pass that test so
i can't tell you how different it is but
um i can just tell you what the pmp is
like maybe you you know what the scrum
certification is like
all right let's see
do you have a link to either of these
two objective statements
i don't but i bet you can google them
i can tell you that the
those statements are
what i said
so the
viking objective was
fly to mars and take pictures in six
years for six billion dollars
the uh the objective for the
for the apollo program was
to achieve a manned lunar landing and
safe return of the astronauts
by the end of 1970 had a cost not to
exceed
40 billion dollars by the way how they
do they uh the project ended up costing
36 billion dollars so it's one of those
few government projects that came in
under budget
they were successful on their schedule
right they they were
had a man on the moon by
the summer of 1969
and they brought that person back safely
so there it was a successful project
let's see i think provide the states
with gdk yeah we talked about that
let's see what's next
can i get a copy of this presentation
sure attend the class and uh you'll have
a copy i'll have to turn that question
over to um
to that question over to the
administrator i'd be happy to share um
the one non-single third slide with you
guys and um
i don't
i think this is actually recorded and
you can see
what this is
all right let's move on
just for a second bruce that is correct
they do record the recordings and then i
believe afterwards they will be a place
you can down you can go in and view the
recording and go back over it
okay good
here's some more um
uh
what the leader needs to do at this
point um
you know you need to
these guys are looking to the leader for
guidance then there's people arguing
amongst themselves during storming and
trying to get a voice
the mission is defined now
we need to make sure everyone's on the
same page and then during the performing
notice the uh
the central person is not doing that
much all this all the collaboration is
going on outside of the project which is
great we would want to
want to get to that point where the team
becomes self-sustaining
all right more questions let me go back
here
all right what happened to my chat
window there it is
how do we identify the boss type okay so
identify the boss type
like i said the office is pretty easy
desk is clear
wall of fame behind them
they do tend to dress very
conservatively so
in the u.s that would be wearing a
business suit and tie
um
they they're not going to wear crazy tie
with all kinds of colors it's going to
be kind of muted
but really you identify them by
listening to the way they talk they
don't care about people they they
put noses out of joint all the time
they just want to get things
accomplished they want to achieve things
that's how you recognize them
okay next one
we'll be covering
the strategies on which pm style to use
when following one of these personality
types which is leaving for example when
replacing a red extrovert one may choose
a blue black strategy
well
i
i've been a project manager for some 30
years i've never had a lot of say in who
my team members are my team members are
usually
who's available who has the right skill
set
and um
who the functional manager
decides to free up for that particular
job i don't get to have a choice of five
people and pick the one whose
personality matches my my project the
best so unfortunately i don't think
that's a uh
that's a likely way of doing things
all right so patty said she's familiar
with this and not so much with myers
briggs
oh you do have all your letters what i
wonder what your letters are you can
type in your letters i i by the way i'm
at e
for extrovert
n for intuitive e t
f j i'm definitely judging i'm feeling
all right
for the pmp exam if we are confident
with personality and how to relate will
that be enough for example yeah all you
need to know from is briggs is that it
exists
and it may be a pmp question like a
person is uh etfj is that's an example
of a myers-briggs
disc
um
or two other crazy personality styles
that that would be as detailed as it
would get it's not going to say such and
such as uh displays this type of
personality what what would be that
myers-briggs
letters now that would be a little too
complex
all right let's see what else we have
uh
is there a matrix a set of
questionnaires you can plot yes
absolutely there's uh olivia asked is
there a matrix or a set of questions you
could use to figure out where people
feel in the quadrant there's any number
of books myers-briggs has a lot of
questions but then they have 16
different boxes to put people in
the book i used to come up with this boy
i probably should have brought that out
i don't remember the name of the book
but it's
i'm like working with different
personalities if you go to the bookstore
you can find any number of books on
personalities and styles and they'll
always have a list of questions you can
ask
and
you know just pull out that list it's a
great thing to give to the team
um people who actually tend to like
the the
most are the analytical type why because
they love the numbers right
but
as a project manager you may not have
the
authority to administer these tests a
lot of people human resources get a
little upset if you start handing out
personality tests to people
so um
you can ask them hey by the way did you
ever do a myers-briggs what was your
type and
the e versus
i will tell you whether introverted
versus extroverted
and just observe you know i've given you
some ways of looking at different people
you can observe and see and
based on your
judgment you can figure out where they
stand
all right uh somebody said hard to hear
you i think it might move that's not
good hopefully um
that's been solved is it any better now
yes bruce you were just cut out for just
a minute do you i'm gonna interrupt you
just for a moment um while we're
answering questions is it okay if i go
ahead and start the five minute poll
that we kind of put in here
go ahead
okay i'm going to go ahead and launch
that and feel free to keep going down
there if you want i can go ahead and
fill the questions either way
okay i'll keep going down but i
understand there's a poll out there so
please go ahead and answer the
answer the poll
all right let's see keeping current
phase in view as we move into agile
agility and there is no precise role
defined for project manager agile how
does a pmp certification help in this
area
yeah you know that's a that's a really
good question
so here's the thing if you are in the it
industry
agile is taking over
um
and the reason for that is agile is is
well designed for
projects that are very iterative you
know you got to build it you got to test
it you got to
redesign it rebuild re-test and it's
very short cycle
i tend to not personally be involved in
those projects i tend to work in larger
pharmaceutical projects medical device
projects steel mills
projects that last um
you know a minimum of six months
sometimes out to 15 years in length
so agile really hasn't caught hold there
other than there's sometimes you have
little testing cycles within these large
projects like that
so pmp certification is certainly very
useful
outside the it industry now how
how useful is in the it industry it is
still very useful because
a lot of the skills that you
learn within um
within
taking your pmp test are still very
applicable to
it industries it's not just
getting the work done within the agile
they're still creating a project plan
they're still dealing with other
people's communication management
they're still
dealing with the scope of the project
getting the project done on
time meeting all the quality
requirements all of those skill sets are
still very much required about the only
thing within the pmp
test that may not be applicable to the
agile part is is when you're actually
setting up a waterfall type schedule so
i believe that being a pmp is still very
valuable across all industries
being a scrum master is so far only a
valuable within the it industry i would
suggest getting both of those
certifications if you are in the it
industry which i suspect you are
next question
i probably don't know the answer what is
the difference for scrum master itil and
pmp
i kind of described the difference
between scrum master and pnp i i don't
actually know what itil is so
i'm not the right person to answer but i
bet there's somebody in the audience who
doesn't know the answer so
if you do um please feel free to to
share that with the with kiran who has
that question
all right patty says i'm a d
d which one is the d
um
i don't remember all right for the
qualification how does one document the
4 500 hours of experience
that is the hardest thing to do i got to
tell you that that's a
a pain but the way you need to think
about it when i did it i was like how am
i going to prove this the 4 500 hours of
experience you have to prove is that
you've been managing or been team member
on projects for
at least 4 500 hours which is equates to
a little over two years of solid effort
so the way to think about it is document
it in a way that
you could be audited and could answer
with a straight face yes i did do that
so what does that mean don't try to get
to every level of detail how many hours
did i really spend um initiating this
project was it 15 hours or was it 18
hours you don't need to be at that level
of detail what the way i do it is i look
at the
projects i've worked on so i grab my
resume and look at all the projects i've
worked on and go back to five years ago
okay let's see i worked on this project
that part of this project that this
first project
it was probably let's see i worked on it
for three years and it was about 30 of
my time so that is
2 000 hours of effort okay
now within that
most of it was executing so of the
of the thousand hours of effort let's
say
of the 2000 hours of effort let's say it
was
1600 executing the next big chunk was
planning so let's say it was uh 200
hours of planning and then that leaves
100 hours for
money and controlling and some for
initiating several closings so if you
have that
those broad strokes then you can then
you can uh
say okay i worked 100 hours on
initiating this project and what did i
do i did this i did that and you write
down the five things that you did during
that time
that's the best way to do it
you know don't get hung up on
exactly how many hours you you worked on
every single project and initiating
monitoring controlling etc just figure
out the percentages are going to be
pretty similar for most projects
hopefully that answers your question
success ratio for candidates appearing
for pmp overall
i don't know what it is for overall i
know for simply learn something 98.6 of
our graduates pass the pmp
overall i would say it's probably 100
non-joking um overall
probably people who don't get any
training at all it's probably around 70
so it's quite a bit of
of an improvement if you take uh boot
camp like this
uh randy says it's better now i'm glad
to hear that do you suggest a separate
communication for each type of
personality
in fact how do you recommend to handle
the steering committee with different
personality style teddy oh yeah good
question all right so
first of all
no matter who you're talking to
kind of smooth out your edges if you're
near one of the corners of that
personality style
you need to smooth out your edges
because you're annoying most people
all right so um really take a good look
at yourself
uh take one of those personality tests
ask other people hey am i a little too
far on the extreme over here and if you
are smooth out those edges right
then
when you're dealing with uh the question
is do you suggest a separate
communication for each type of
personality in certain cases yes i had a
situation actually
partially work related
i had um
i was an immigrant from australia to
america and uh i'd gone to school and
then i had no money and i worked
and then i had no time
and i i hadn't gone back to australia
for 14 years and so i
was switching from one job to another
and the big my big ask was now that i
have the time and the money
i would like to take a four weeks off
between jobs and go visit australia
so i didn't know who i was going to talk
to because i had accepted the position
but i now needed to do the negotiations
for start date
so i reversed in my head how am i going
to say this four different ways now if i
was going to talk to a a boss type
personality i would say
all right my start date is going to be a
month from now
that's the way it is and boom that's it
and that that person would have accepted
it that's when you can start okay good
that's the facts we're done
if it was an analytical type of person i
would have been
so it's been 14 years since i last
visited australia
all five of my family members are going
to be there during this one period of
time
i need to take the four weeks off now
because now i have the money and the
time to to accomplish this so um
my start date needs to be such a such a
date right numbers numbers numbers
if it was going to be a a
extroverted type of person i would have
been hey how's it going listen i'm
really excited to work here it's a
wonderful place you know voice wanted to
work at this company
looks great i love all the things you do
here you got a great
christmas party and and company picnic
looking forward to being there playing
on your volleyball team you know this is
all really exciting oh by the way i i
i need to start on
september 30th instead of the first step
but that's okay cool and then start
talking about other things just kind of
slip it in there beat around the bush
and get to it as it was the person i
walked in the office she was wearing
pastel colors muted makeup pictures of
her family on the wall ah analytical uh
hey a amiable type so what i did was i i
walked to her and i said
hey um you know it's
i see your family it's really nice i've
got a lot of family too my family's all
in australia it's been a long time since
i've seen it my sister who had been
traveling for had been living in
malaysia for a long time she's now back
in australia but she's only there for
for a two-month period um i was hoping
that i could take this this break
between projects to rather than start
right away i could i could start a month
from now and uh and work there and go to
australia you know so i had a different
way of dealing with it
based on the different personality tile
style now the question was what do you
do when you're dealing with the steering
committee there i just suggest trying to
get as close to the middle as possible
so you're not annoying anybody and
ask for ask for what you want in a very
non
non-confrontational way
all right oh somebody answered itil itil
is the certification within the iti i.t
world service
infrastructure
library great to have all right so
um
somebody said that
that's important there you go
so i t people should do pmp or what yes
absolutely ashish i t people should get
their pmp it's like i said the the scrum
master that's that's still valuable
but that is
for the build test
rebuild re-test that that portion of the
project which is only part of the
project the pmp teaches you a lot more
else about the project like how to
conduct the procurements how to deal
with stakeholders how to um
how to maintain a scope change control
all of these things are still very
valuable for
any kind of a project manager so i
recommend that it people should
definitely get that
okay
i'm not i.t but need my pmp what is the
best way to approach study for the pmp
so the simply learn approach is actually
pretty good
what they've what they do is
and frankly when i teach the class
very few my students actually do this
which is disappointing but the right way
to do it is
you're immediately given access to the
website and there's all these e-learning
processes set up on there so you every
day you open one up and you go through
the half hour class maybe it's a
two-hour class
and you learn about each different
section there's like 16 different
sections in there
then when you feel like you've you
understand that the best way then is to
take the live class so it's a four day
pmbok
boot camp where there's an instructor
like myself there they go through those
same slides but they put their own spin
on it and you get a chance to ask the
questions that you had while you were
while you were going through the classes
by yourself
so you uh you have this interaction the
person like when i'm done i have flip
charts
taped up to all the walls with all the
additional stuff i've added in there
then you
um so you take the class then on day
four you take a practice exam after the
practice exam i'll go through or the
instructor will go through all the
questions with you and clear up some
misunderstandings and
you probably will fail that the fail is
pass fail pmi doesn't actually advertise
but it's probably still around 70
percent
so if you get lower than 70 percent you
feel a little bit bad but now you'll
you'll look at the results and see the
areas of which you are weak so then
there's five more practice tests so you
study those
practice tests you study that area take
another practice test see how you did
go to the areas that you did poorly on
re-study that take another practice test
keep doing this iteration until you've
gone through all five and then as soon
as you've taken that last one and you're
up around the 85 pass rate go take the
test because all this knowledge i've
given you and that you're taking in this
class
is uh slowly leaking out your ears you
want to make sure you take the official
test as soon as possible
all right we're pretty much at the end
of the half hour so is there anything
else richard you need to do before we
shut it down
no that was wonderful bruce thank you
very much we very i appreciate you being
here so what was the result of the poll
what what happened i didn't see oh here
is the poll what was the question
uh they were simply learned questions
about following up on certification uh
training oh i see okay got it all right
cool
any last questions before we go it is
the top the bottom of the hour top of
the hour for you guys
if not i appreciate your time and your
attention and good luck on your on your
getting your pmp and good luck in your
careers and enjoy your projects
bye for now
you